welcome it's my pleasure to well
nandi as alonso this terms Lou
on visiting assistant professor welcomed
into we've welcomed into the school but
now to the platform of Hastings Hall the
con visiting assistant professorship
enables our school to invite young
architects to offer advanced design
studios and to conduct seminars previous
con visiting assistant professors
include Greg pasquarelli William
Sharples and Chris Sharples of the firm
shop galia Solomonov Mario Gooden Jeanne
gang cine o bald Sean Griffiths Sam
Jacob and Charles Holland of the firm
fat by secure and Katherine Clark of the
firm muff and last year Eric bungay and
Mimi wang of n architects and Chris
Perry were each con professors Hernandez
Alonso was born in Argentina where he
began his professional training at the
National University of Rosario before
working in the office of mariah's target
ugly aboue in Barcelona and then coming
to New York to receive advanced
professional training at Columbia after
graduating from Columbia in 1999 and a
year as a senior designer in Peter
Eisenman office professor Diaz Alonso
founded Severo tark or whatever it's
called ok say it I came almost close i
was pretty good without coaching i was
pretty good with offices in Los Angeles
a practice that operates at the cutting
edge of digitally determined
architecture in 2005 assiduous Alonso at
designed the summer pavilion ps1 in Long
Island City he has taught at the
university of applied arts in vienna as
adjunct associate professor at Columbia
and his distinguished professor at
Southern California Institute of Art
Chris I arc where he is graduate thesis
coordinator in 2011 Thames and Hudson
will publish a monograph of trustee has
long does work please join me in
welcoming Hernandez oldest lecture
tonight
well whoo I always liked the idea that
because we like to play God but some my
god that's way too much team is found
thank you so much for inviting me to be
here it goes without saying that you're
at one of the great leaders in the field
and your vision and hearing very
generous too if responsible people like
me to have any spot in a great place
like these also be coming here for many
years be a mortgage who partially
responsible for me being here so
everything goes wrong we can blame it on
here that that's the reason why we can
turn off the lights so these good people
can take it up
don't need to see me I appreciate for
you guys be here thursday night that
talks about the volume of your
commitment to architecture order your
social life starts either way thank you
for being here so I'm not gonna explain
the title of the lecture from the
beginning I hope that that begin more
the conclusion at the end but most three
or four years ago at mark I don't
remember mr. Galton's important three is
whether I start to use a clip then we
can very useful for me to spend what we
do and maybe some of you already saw it
but I still thought it would be nice to
bring it back so i'll show you the clip
and then we get this show on the road
I think we're ready to wear this first
track down by the way my name is Bruce
Dickinson yes I gotta tell it fellas you
have got what appears to be a dynamite
sound coming from your Bruce that means
a lot yeah Bruce sticks this is
incredible I can't believe Bruce fixing
dinner set easy guys I put my pants on
just like the rest of you one leg at a
time except once my pants are on I make
gold bracket here we go if you don't
fear the reaper take one rope right one
two three four
you
now it's gonna be a great track guys
what's the deal but you sure that was
sounding okay i'll be honest fellows it
was sounding great but i could be used a
little more cowbell so let's take it
again Angie yeah really explore the
studio space this time you got a little
bit yeah explore the space I like what
I'm here go one two three four
anyway my point is amazing what we do in
the office and when I mean we roll away
is it is more cowbell in the sense of we
only know one or two things and we find
opportunities to see when we can amber
the volume even if it takes us almost to
the borderline of the grotesque button
like what what I'm trying to argue in
relation to this thing is that mostly
the thing that we were talking about us
sorry just trying to put my timer here
so I don't go beyond one hour have to do
what I would say the word has been
involved in in the in the last eight or
nine years we have the office and I'm
going to go very fast to the very first
to the first part and then I'm going to
focus mostly in the world that we would
go into the last 33 years but ultimately
has been and they begin in driven more
by the notion of technique and more for
the notion of a kind of a pure interior
Latino thana me with a permanent form on
the relational form as the vehicle for
the production of architecture and in
that sense I always like to use the work
of Francis Bacon is the perfect example
in terms of ambition in sense of he
never meant to radicalize to innovate in
terms of the techniques of the
methodology the discipline what he tried
to figure it out was decent alternative
millions of effective quality and
aesthetics and visions and ultimately a
kind of a provocation in relation with
the audience but within the internment
conditions of the of its own field in
this case painting now in architecture
to me what is a couple of things are all
said the beginning is one is I don't
believe that architecture is so capable
of new or newness I think architecture
at best can be about innovation about
reconfiguration about how things can be
organized so in that sense to me deltana
me of form drop to form a detective talk
to architecture is the only way to
progress and I think in one way or
another it's kind of a an evolutionary
logic but although
we are interest in the prone form is
have to do with prone of geometry have
to do with a permanent representation in
this case is remember yeah how to lay
out a croissant which I find really
interesting that you have to convey
conventional information to
unconventional use conventional
information to convey and convention
form now in terms of the evolution of
the world the world and we were
producing has been incredibly embedded
in the illusionist technology and
political shift and happen in my view
the last 10 or 15 years couple of them
only one is the notion of evolution of
the notional representation in the road
notion of simulation the notions of
kailash modeling what i call pixelated
balls and then the last one which is the
one and more fascinated man injured and
interested in is the illusion of
geometry or geometry of control of
geometries for the production of form
was replaced from the image or as a
vehicle for the production of form and
three that kind of a key part of the
argument because originally i didn't
want it to be an architect not a claim
that i am an architect when L that is
still open for debate but my original
intention was to spell filmmaking and
for you to be chemical maker for
different reasons which is a long story
to tell now we did I couldn't do it
another time India so I didn't become
her in architecture so when the ability
of animation software and English real
software became available that 24 for me
was kind of an interesting moment to
start to figure it out how to operate
mean that but i will say in the early
stages of the world this is 2003-2004
sorry the projectors clapping on the
left the names of the project and the
years nah let me make that much of a
difference but just to give yourselves
with one year the work they were all
about they'd say embedded with that work
at that time I was investigating the
mall so we
was the articulation of similar size is
trying to produce as much as we can in
terms of formal organization and so on i
would i would argue that most of the
work that we were producing at a time it
didn't have like a very clear agenda in
terms of what word ambitions even though
i only have an intuition that what i was
interesting was that have to do with the
condition of aesthetic and it comes with
the condition to break away with any of
the candles in which former behavior
relation to effects effects anesthetic
was operating but i would call it more
like experiments because there were a
select conditions I didn't amount to any
inner research or any kind of a clarity
but the previous project had to show to
me stuff to introduce certain kind of
interesting quality which is 211 another
thing in one way or another still
influence cook the war than we produce
which is it start to convey condition
over a test or a kind of wave yeah a
protest quality to the work which at the
beginning I will say like most of the
people i confuse it with something that
people also say we discussed in or awful
but actually the origin of the word
grotesque have to do with something that
it cannot be categorized or argon
organized on any kind of aesthetic
cannon at any given time like for
example the work of summer electrons is
covering is black period was catalogue a
securities because it didn't fit with
the cannons were word aesthetic
apparatus i will be fine in painting
under time so the byproduct of
computational work and surface world and
proliferation of that i start to create
a sense of emerging qualities they would
not really orchestrate an uncontrolled
by us but it was more like a by protocol
default quality that was coming with
vocabulary that the tools were producing
but that conditional start to happen to
me even though i was an evolution and i
was in the search of
beauty search the work he was coming
with this kind of a group text quality
now as I just mentioned grotesque is
more like an emerging quality is not
it's not something that you can
completely career for the to spray
another work in other terms protects to
me is like the opposite of cute is
something that like if somebody set up I
have a friend I want to introduce you
she or he whatever is your cup of tea
you said is she or he beautifully said
well he or she is cute you know that
their meaning something else you have to
do relate you have to do a personality
but it will not be something that can be
established under certain time now the
other thing which is tough to happen is
the original which is kind of close to
protest to me was another medium that we
can start to achieve explore the
permanent beautiful and go back to that
later analytic could be something that
can correlate that can produce a can
affected quality and like many of us
than we are interesting the problem for
most won't affect and the definition the
layers of bacon brother land we came
like an interesting concept but the
condition of horrific it can be
choreographic an orchestra and it can
produce a different logic of sensation a
different kind of seduction and
ultimately produce a condition of desire
like if you think in for example cycle
of ultraheat code the famous shall we
see you can imagine that the editing
room they can choreograph the reaction
that I would produce anyway so in terms
of specific of the techniques and
evolution of the techniques as an
apparatus for devolution of the world
some of the previous more than we were
producing what these singular surfaces
but it was not enough because it will
produce an again delayed by probable
incremental variation too much
continuity so one of the thing that we
start to do it when we get invited to
submit the proposal for ps1 in New York
if we start to work in
first attempt to start to work with a
little bit of scripting and variations
and the idea of a topological model of a
singular cell that can have a pretty
wide range of variation of the scene of
a singular ontology and we start to
orchestrate his sternum equality of
organization and growth and it was the
first time that a name in our own work
we start to sprout responsibility now
part of the tricky part with this also
was the this fascination and I have the
image was becoming more and more press
in terms of the work so I wanted to see
I wanted to start the war with the
possibilities of animation and films as
a way to design and not just a way to
represent such as a way to simulate the
logics of sensation of their visions of
seduction that we wanted the project
work so while ensuring to use the same
thing and we show to the to the people
in the community to get the project um
not so we decide not to reveal the whole
project but the idea was to produce like
the camera sees of effect i will try to
capture that Wichita quality who tried
to produce the variation and so on and
so forth so some we are at can happen
and we want and to me my obsession was I
wanted to build the project pavilion to
look as close as as close as we can to
the render to make a look at heart
official and we could and no the other
way around so the idea to use that
condition and establish that now the
other part of the thing is when when we
did be as one at that time they will
give you eight weeks since you will to
build it for a very bad a small budget
and so a lot of the technology and tell
me became very handy to start to figure
it out how we can do this 1432 pieces of
the structure they were all different
and that's one of the moment you start
to wonder why the hell I'm not a
minimalist
because in creating a huge project and
for those of you who are skilled at the
audience one piece of advice are
learning competition is when you go
bring your eat engineer with you and
make sure there is an engineer with a
British accent it goes long way
committees to convince and you know what
you doing so as a matter of fact the
engineer and came with us almost not
even engineer the work with us in the
project he never saw it but when the
committee asked is this thing is going
to hold and I said well I'm going to let
my engineer to answer and the only thing
that he said was but of course and that
was it and we got it and anyway so
here's one was an interesting challenge
because we were trying to cross over
which he sends it that interests me a
lot and now looking back four years
after it was kind of the beginning of
what I will say is where I'm interested
the most and I think it's one of the
most interesting product war with the
gem bruh this particular gender which is
a product of mystery I will say part of
the thing is we have their very high-end
tech cover brocation part with very
obsolete and and classical mechanics and
service so at the end of the day to me
was never in jammies today is not a
little and a religious approach to the
condition of technology but is more to
the mission of the technique as a
mechanism to produce a certain logic and
can keep evolving and ultimately what I
call is to develop a sense of a species
so to me is a natural evolution from
type we went to to topology the notion
of production of a species and mutation
of this patient became like a very
obsessive condition and start to work
and one of the things and actually
enjoyed it's always even though my
office is probably one of the most
unsuccessful offices of architecture in
the whole world I always liked then we
work in four or five perfect on the same
time on different scales because I mean
within the ideas of families of a
species idea that you can really a
consciousness of cells that can grow
into multiple quality so through
different experiments and many
that they were nowhere like it was a
series of experiment that we did for
nokia about the future of that game was
on product presentation and so on but in
each other will try to explore certain
territory that we were interesting with
this program of cellular aggregation
mutation that they can produce organs
they can create alternative way of
organization so in this Foley in
Dominican Republic you know that they
think and piss me the most feeds me up
the mouse about the projector cutting
dad and i spend like two hours writing
on the text about what project and year
were it's not showing up so leave an urn
i will never write the text again but in
any case part of that was okay how did
they say conventional frozen turkey
church you can stop to negotiate a
friction with this oh how those kind of
a sphere systems or windows or apertures
and start to figure out those colonel
problem so despite how side fiction 04
in the world can look there always is
they always done with an architectural
mission with the level of precision they
try to articulate how the things try to
go together some of the pressure we take
it further no no one yeah yeah other
ones but they always a kind of a desire
to have a level of understanding of that
quality of precision the other thing
which became very clear to me that we
had a desire to oscillate the project
and we do as much as we came out the
context as much as we can in relation
with the side and almost do it us immune
as we can to external factors on
contamination i will say at that time i
will say the war right now expecting a
different path but this this condition i
was talking about the rific and they
ritesh i became like an interesting
vehicle for me to start to think about
the problem of the difference between
beauty and beautiful i seeded us as big
as possibilities to explore these
aesthetic problems in a different
territory I
the notion of desire and ultimately last
are critical in the pursue of the world
it doesn't pretend to have any kind of
intellectual depth but try to rely much
more in cannibal and more nothing sorry
but more like an internal that driven by
desire relationship with but did how to
put it in a way that makes sense did for
me I might want into something beautiful
than beautiful the following reasons I
think beauty is a much more classical
permanent value that I think you have
very clear rules I think what we do like
musi and solo show that is on an SF MoMA
that we try to model and so on but also
there's a kind of an ambition of a
pedagogical way to show the work like
the work is never revealed is much more
about how the cells through the
animation grow into something else and
how that we came in these places and so
on but it is always an ambition to hide
any kind of clear moral process I mean
that something i always find
uncomfortable with a big change about
this idea that we have like a more
holistic approach to it that everything
has to be like in linear quality and
less on the final effects I'm much more
interested I corrupt logic that can more
from discipline I feel making that i
would say architecture and this product
beauty and beautiful I think you goes
into that condition I think beautiful is
much more contemporary and temporary
problem he have like a limit it doesn't
became external it will change over time
and I'm okay with that I don't have any
problem with that and I'm interested in
working with that I think goes back to
this ambition of species and permanent
state of mutation how the work can keep
evolving in their own logic and also to
start to develop their own internal
logic and how the thing is that the ball
so from one singular cell we start to
work with projects that are generating
by two families of cells and then those
families of cells canister
very precise maps or character in which
the pressure get deployed this is a this
is an installation for the Pompidou
Center he was the first person than we
did in 2008 we had that work we are in
different phase now now we reschedule
for 2012 so we are working a different
version but ultimately at this point the
work is start to solve and we start to
negotiate friction with thermal forces
and product I mean common problems and
other people in warning like ornament
and three-dimensional ornament and the
possibility we have it ornament they
start to also in parallel like you see
an installation we were working it
working in a pedestrian bridge for
Puerto Rico and that I've been going
back to this notion of the corruption I
was talking about that interests me a
lot about the filmmaking and illusion of
editing a way as a process to operate
much more than a linear one the idea
that you can film out of segments other
sequence and then report together but
also the corruption between the
mechanical with the digital was so on
and ultimately about all of the final
effect but by then in this is to south
now we are in 2007 this was a small
private competition in Paris an art
galleries who owned the house of under
block invite 45 architect firm to
propose a guest house with the gallery
and but around this time was when I
thought the year of the singular
topological sell in work anymore an idea
of the corruption and misfit between
more than one origin of organization can
start to amplify the palette and how
these different conditions can expect to
introduce new possibilities for the side
effects and ultimately for many
generations and going more and more in
that in the using animations and see
magic effect to start to develop the
project so the person will start to
realize much more in this kind of a
cinematic ambition and much less attic
and of course a architectonic ambition
so part of the thing is in relation to
the technique is always kind of a direct
relation between the Volusion from a
spline curve to nurse her face to
subdivision to polygons particles
scripting three-dimensional space
interaction so we always try to figure
it out what kind of techniques are
available relation to the technology and
figure it out basically how we can screw
them start to define a territory which
almost a system or the logic of that
technique can put to the verge of
collapse and of course I still have a
fascination with plants and not so much
resection I always suck a section I
still do in very bad a section three
plans were a little bit better but i
think this collapse the the contemporary
techniques allows us that all the
elements that he used to be broken into
multiple parts potentially we can
collapse into one condition I think he
force us to rethink all the time what is
the relation between drawings and
renders and image not being just a trend
representation but being the thing but
himself and the image as being the
vehicle for the production of the form
how in that logic also you can start to
think and speculate about how you can
assemble it how you can fabricate it and
maybe a certain intelligent and you can
start to develop in terms of repetition
which is hidden and it doesn't look like
a repetitive but isn't there but I will
not I will not deny them still the main
driving force is how old are you
decide on the production of Messiah or
not and to be more specific I will say
because effect it seems such a general
world to understand almost kind of empty
by now my i will say make the kirk the
most the current amnesia in relation
today's argue that is closer to the
notion of arousal so I think arouse are
also to miss me much more interesting
and beautiful or even which have to do
is I don't know I am I can approve then
architecture escape k pod capable of
that I cannot prove that what we do is
capable of that but i think is super fun
and super interesting and very
stimulating to keep rolling that
possibility then architecture gonna have
a different kind of attitude the other
thing whether i will say is this is part
of the reverse engineer than we did in
which for show at the bank center in
Vienna with so little there which we
start formless and then we started
developer season out of that as another
way to corrupt internal logic that the
work was building every time that the
project started game very coherent and
very organized I always try to push in a
different direction so in that sense
this this show was very useful in
relation to that but also because it was
not a pavilion I'm becoming because if
it was not a building proposal or a
house or eating like that but it was a
series of object we can really focus
only on the pure effects of the thing
and try to see we can create a scary
cinematic quality to articulation of
parts and produce a simulation of
difference even though the bodies are
all the same the only thing that
difference of the legs may invasion that
is what we're trying to achieve that
condition but also perfect eva tea and
poop ultra shine ultra shiny effect that
the
a sense of almost like scallops which is
another footnote in terms of what
interests me with the world I'm explore
weren't one of the most compelling
things about compute a tional
territories to me is precisely that you
can work in a final escapist environment
to a point that's a design problem and
it doesn't need to have preconditions in
relation to that and I think that has an
incredible level of freedom and of
course is clear by now then I have a
very vested interest in a high level of
the structure will speculate all these
problems and that's what I always talk
in terms of a species and I also
probably noticed by now that we have a
tendency for excess and excessiveness we
never edit anything out and you can have
a new logic that this species can evolve
into something else it's just Adi so
that's what I said it is more cowbell we
just keep adding stuff so
three-dimensional ornament okay we can
put that on top of cells okay it's a
nice table structures or what uninsured
and we keep adding and two at one point
it will not be able to hold anything
else but so far I don't think we got to
that point yet but the idea all this
work is sifted 2007 the previews the
competition for a concert hall this is a
new version for much more exponent
pavilion for this woman in Paris so they
say that already was study as a guest
house now became more like a garden
gathering area but at the same time that
you work with the concert hall in the
way that each of the species keep
evolving you inform the other one sort
from the concert hall you go to this
which is almost like a furniture scale
and the cells instantly start to get
more complex instead to be only three
cells each of the cells from you take
from one to two to three so any games
almost like natural artificiality
horrendous situations of these benches
that we were proposing for that they
became slowly into a lounge chair
then we start from the eames chair and
we start to contaminated with series of
virus script then we were developing all
the time that goes into manufacturing
and then to be finished pain is
somewhere and then you realize when it's
finished my natural tendencies I hate
everything that we do and have some that
is done I cannot watch it again I mean
it's one of the big problems I have with
architecture it takes way too long and I
thought that doing some ink or sealing
products i will take some of that and
Charlie out no miss words it takes
pretty much the same amount of time to
get anywhere the only difference is you
can be more control of the prototype and
so on so you can run a couple of tricks
here there and it's kind of interesting
because you have it very direct
relationship but the other thing then
you learn is doesn't matter how much you
try to hide it at the end you work and
your brain words in the way the rewards
and as much as I spy and I'll try to
always walk on the edge of the
discipline about being an avid and so on
every program that we work on it at the
end of the day I think as a nap even
though they can be more like an artistic
effect in a museum or the probe aside
when you talk to our d zone you talk to
produce I know when you talk to
filmmaker you realize that the way that
you think have nothing to do that the
way that they think and they operate and
basically I like that they're like a
here happy access I like that
architecture is a fairly insecure
discipline I go back to the second this
was two years ago they like my know a
hammer museum in los angeles the liquid
prospective on John London and they bite
for architects Dylan re will condemn
myself at I forgot was a fourth each of
us we get one of the famous houses of
longer would get the keys here and we
supposed to add thirty percent but going
back to this and what were the animation
play going back to this notion of
security of them we have a
we always try to me something out in the
sexy we were interested in sociology and
politics politics 70 philosophy any sort
of but art 90 we went 70 scientific
right now I'm not so sure what we are
but to me that one of the interesting
thing about that is always allowed to
miss really so to meet idea that you can
jump in the probe design or entertaining
which is certain stuff that we doing
right now for capitals from nickel
Nickelodeon or go back to more to take a
more kind of like current version or
material at the end of the day I like to
think that what we do at the end I
always thinking like an architect and
the battles are we working with a start
to the deal with that so it's dream
articulations of the surfaces and what I
call Micro Micro condition with truly
are Mike rejest Oh in other words that
you can overload the basic cells with a
lot of different variables and you can
work but also multiple overlapping
between those logics of articulation of
geometry with Foley kills with hair
things I start to move around my
fascination with cartoons and my my
obsession with I don't know factual
Sadie's such a graceful and ideas that I
have a personal interest in pornography
of the seventies because it was a time
they were trying to fake it to be a real
film because it still was shown in
theaters so they will give you basically
a team and of bad movies with ten
minutes of sex and I always liked it
because it's almost about all of our sex
and VCRs and DVD player killed that
because you can fast-forward to the sec
so they lost any sense of five movies
and they went directly for the sex so in
that sense I'm have a kind of
vaccination for that that the word the
word that we produce it goes only for
the sales we are left primitive and I am
that primitive and it took me look for
four years after I cry
columbia columbia being the peak of the
sales of scientific Savior philosophical
whatever it took me four or five years
to accept that about myself but the
moment that you said that life it easier
and faster and so on so the evolution of
there's a setting ambition and the
quality that we were trying to produce
to the world if he came also a territory
to for us to keep exploring in improv
design this is it the first version of a
silverware collection and with it for a
lesson is from a year ago these are the
prototype term we did for them and we
call it mutant manners so actually none
of them were completed properly they're
kind of dangerous so you can tell you
can count yourself how I always been
fascinated by Cronenberg ringers or a
tourist hour in Dubai which is destroyed
by far the worst thing that we were done
but i think is just fair to show you to
you guys that very bad pain this is
terrible in my defense also wait for the
last two days but in parallel to one
weirdo an elastic we got this commission
which is the only commission and we
still have alive well III I would say is
in coma these not brain dead yet but
it's close they forgot to show you is it
to tell you is the first project and I
shows a park in Lexington Kentucky in
2001 now we want the competition then we
won't be as one all the other
competition then I show you we lost all
of them so I don't need to spray it one
by one with it this one we lost and of
course we all have a great excuse what
we lost like any architect will tell you
the jury well we were we were the
winners but then something happened no I
mean we have a lot of honorable mentions
which is a good way to set up well it is
pretty cool but there's no way we'll
ever do
but in any case there is something about
what I always liked our white wily
coyote which is the idea that you keep
insisting even though never in a really
quite work but in any case this is a
small Museum pavilion but I own in
Argentina for the Titian Bonham is a
collection in Vienna G decide to have
three is ma museum pavilions in
different parts of the world that she
can protect her contemporary collection
so this was a first version than we did
and I'm going to finish today lecture
with the latest version which is with
finishing like a couple of months ago by
the idea was to also start to this one
probably is the most clear example when
we start with 1 i'm talking about the
mistake i think by definition one of the
problems and i have personally let's say
with parametrics and the more
specifically approach to the problem is
i think it came too much attached to the
formula and it doesn't put so full front
and they decide what the clear mission a
project right to do but also it always
bought by the incremental variations and
to me is much more interesting than we
live in a time that the problem is that
we have too many options that the end
the province is still about this iron is
about still on us it's just we have way
more options and things that we conserve
considered perversions in the past now
they're legally aceptan and everybody
well that certainly bit then we still
have to follow but there is a kind of an
tua set that condition so the problem is
would one day the options became way
more available full of us where do you
operate in the territory that's when I
say and that's what I'm saying that the
notion of midfield is way more
interesting to me the idea that you can
make different species and try to figure
that one into the negotiation not as a
collage model and not as a compositional
model but some kind of a synthetic one
have the way that as I was saying how
cells grown into our own hands organs
they have a capacity police a species
and so on so so the what we did for a
lasik can be translated to understand
for museum in this mob
million which is traffic size of the
health or for an artist elation for
Selfridges in London for the windows or
for a newer version for the installation
of the Pompidou Center and while we this
mark and other moments of devolution of
which i will say i think the same
fiction era in our rific protest work i
will say start to move it slowly for
what i call it came a new romantic
approach for some reason maybe because i
became a father a few years ago suddenly
probably becoming nicer I still don't
care about people and you realize and we
don't show that much people there and I
never make a case about program and so
on but i had to tell you based on my
hardcore modernise argentinian education
i do care about that at those things on
there and you pay attention to some
other plant they do what you have to
take my word for it but there is an a
there is an ethical approach to the
problem that it doesn't go away but as i
will say this condition of new means to
the production of last an arousal as a
mechanism for the temper of beauty that
is an ultimately one to it we started
incorporating when i called pure forms
of pure primitive so as fierce as
silikal start to appear in the work and
I think the moment that a recognizable
geometry stuff to merge in bed in
certain and recognizable species of
mutations of it it start establishing
different relation and this condition of
the be speed is that we came more
evident and the other thing which
interests me more and more is to start
to work in projects on options of
projects then had to negotiate with a
complex and accept the context either
side gallery function whatever you want
to call it as a vehicle for a frictional
of provocative relationship so this
competition that we lost for a meteor
Museum in San service can you explain it
was a little bit about the notion
we wanted to work a lot with existing
structure of the building so in one way
was an opportunity to start to develop
another variation of this cellular
system to start to have like a much more
cartilage logically say or more they
realized modern geometry and less
primitive to understand so it would
allow that to have more flexibility than
times and how we relate to the existing
contacts and to the existing internal
logic of it I personally still related
the autonomous project of architecture
is more alike than ever and I think in
the context and we are that is more
necessary than ever and I will never
claim that what we do is a critical
project or have a lot of criticality
built into it because the truth is many
many of these thought that I try to
throw at you in a very Hardy fashion
there are things i think about you want
to have to do later like this one but
it's not then we dry the work in those
terms i'm not in the other thinking all
these variables i have a much more day
by day basis relation with the work it's
much more like in the way that you will
cook bread or you make the bed in the
morning it's like a you develop business
ability you develop a logic about doing
it and you do it and a naturally move
from one to the other and you tweak a
little bit of that and in that sense is
much more like a jam session in the way
the music will were then you keep
tweaking here and there than to have
like a huge Ten Commandments changing
the wall that you should know that you
should do that i'll leave that Patrick
Schumacher an eventual father
parametrics we getting is fine but
religious is never the
so as you can see the devolution of how
this start to organize and now get me
wrong we use the scripting and we use
particles I will you see brush and we
use anything that we can put in our
hands on that we think it can help to
the cost to the cost of everything in
the issues but at the end of the day we
only work in two or three burials and I
would have said that and I would argue
that that leaves the body of work in
architecture and art or music on film
that always interest me the most they're
the one and they relate with this
condition of excessive exuberant quality
the atrocity if you want and so at the
end of the day you build your work or
your process or your project or what you
have and what interests you and there is
economic inclusion and goes into that
and not everything is a candidate by
product of a rational attitude towards
so they did as i said this friction
between more prosaic or easy-to-read
geometries kind of stuff we interact
with the one that we produce it belongs
to a different trajectory are more where
the work is going this this mechanism of
misfits are probably what I'd more
invested right now in terms of the work
is and these conditions of within these
projects are not so evident but what I
call the romanticism kind of an air
romanticism the V of the decade idea
that the project can keep evolving that
ideally the project and key it's very
relatively and changing and one we did
be as one the bench is completely fall
apart under the hot weather in Europe
because they were fabricated in the dry
weather in LA
remember when we call yourself the New
York 10 critic came to see it already
behind blisters in the material he says
well but that is down corporal because
you're interested in the grotesque um
terrific and said of course yes but the
thing they were seen pleasing to me is
that those things are very interesting
mechanism contamination of any logical
that's something that we can pursue then
that kind of imperfection is something
that upsets me a lot in this relation
with the where I was going with the
mystery this is a competition for the
words of History Museum in Poland
another successful lost but what
interests me about this program is feed
on this problem with perfection and this
is a current version and we work in lse
for a silverware a whole series of other
other products is that one of the most
interesting thing is a static IP
devolution of aesthetic and the
production of sensation was that in the
past painting an architectural so forth
they were trying to convey a perfect
image the idea of God the idea of
aesthetics as an expression of that so
by the techniques and methods were very
perfect but the desire was to create a
sense of perfection I think today with
computational tools and the power of
those things and the power of I Guarini
and algorithms and so on and so forth
they produce very perfect almost closed
systems so the question to me or what
I'm interested is how we can produce
imperfect qualities they can out perfect
systems almost the opposite of where the
traditional aesthetic model has been so
to me to start the develop as I was
saying and keep pushing the first
version
have a go for a lazy we call this
instruments of manner I mean they are
like all based on the dead ringer of
David Cronenberg when the tweens
genealogy they create their own tools
for mutant babies and so on to me those
these things are almost like weapons I
understand that and send them I don't
know how the work how good they will
work on this with the spoon as a spoon
but i'm pretty sure that will force you
to modify your behavior how you relate
to that so there is a kind of extreme
almost take to a stream on with like a
physical presence in relation to that
and that maybe is the next frontier
anything is worth maybe we're going in
the next in the next territory so but
also is not only that in terms of how we
keep refining the cinematic techniques
about not only to represent them to show
but as a way to design and i start 20
micro scale and very innovation yourself
and alter articulated the form surfaces
and formal and ornaments and reflections
and how to start to operate within that
and how the project can keep evolving
from there and sorry let me
condition of the holiday ratio from
there because it's too heavy but also
how you can create a whole family how
you can create a whole vocabulary based
on that alley and I mean is not a
different and created an outfit or
calligraphy or almost like an ecology
that it came from that so let's just
take me let me take 30 seconds of break
this is the corkscrew but this idea that
we are working at very close up witness
of the sciences most is not very it's
not a stylish run away what you're
looking about this this is mall or we're
talking about a larger installation
museum or potentially that this can work
as a building 50 minutes so i have 10
more minutes and they use it doubly not
i really i literally run out of ideas to
tell you but i have a couple of other
images to show you so i'll show it and
i'll probably repeat the only two or
three ideas that i have
and these kids are minors it's too slow
let's see they being we saw this this is
the wine cover and oh ok these are this
is a sealer where think this I am
correct this is a cigar cutter is my
favorite sorry went away yeah this is a
cigar cutter which I think it can be
used for synchronizations as well I
don't know it has now been approved by a
rabbi but I think maybe there is a God
rabbi they will go for it and these are
the plates but ok let's go back to the
images i can show you this later in the
queue name it was like it 20 minutes
animation sorry color let me go back I
don't know why it's doing this keep it
out of recovery thing all the time I'm a
recent convert it to Mike anyway so this
is a corkscrew bottle wine cover the
drawing for it basically after many back
and forth between how we can manufacture
them because unless he have a very
actually obsolete way to produce metal
we come to the conclusion and as we did
for the mac show we're going to print
this in plastic and then chrome there
and they planning to sell it for
first-class air lines or six star hotels
but they're going to be plastic which I
like a lot that they fake notion that
sense it will look really heavy my nose
is going to incredibly light that it is
what it is i mean i tell you probably
sign as pain in the neck as architecture
these are the glass the blood where
bottle glasses and they all have these
are mature than they can be in the table
and they can be part of a normal
then you add so that's what we call it
mutant manners and instrument and he
said these are this is probably the
first inning of will go into production
which of course is it Daisy's one to
manufacture for them which has its a a
system of three trades put together
these are asked rice so for me always a
challenge how much we can articulate and
saturate such a small thing it's an
interesting challenge but jewelleries
have been doing that for years so not
really than new when you think of then
as try and based out of that family we
are developing this display system for a
traveling exhibition so again these the
idea is the create illusion of
difference out of repetition and of
course we have the ipod players but the
idea is this system three parts and you
can have a model than you will change
from city to city and then the iPad will
hold animation this is something that
we're doing with the Pompidou foundation
in the states to raise funds for the big
show is it is a long story this is a
prototype that we are developing right
now in Los Angeles called the worst
chair which is I think this will work
really well in Montana como like a
torture thing but basically is it is
part of this what i was talking the
mystery the idea that instead to produce
complete synthetic thing between the
skin structure is to separate them but
they start to feel like a formal
vocabulary or sensibility that can keep
it together and the other thing which is
something which is a very recent racial
prejudices of me is that include real
flowers that i can go rotten and
deteriorate which Perriman with that
with the small installation than we did
for the marking Los Angeles that we need
instruction marital flowers with a
series of plastic components with DVD
players inside and the show was open for
four months so slowly the flower to
start to deteriorate and develop all
these kind of growth
disgusting thing inside available none
on the DVD players works anymore the
flower-filled technology the structure
still holds sort of but the idea is to
start to incorporate that condition and
this is the next layer to take the
string to the Mean Street and start to
develop again cell system plus ornament
plus articulating surfaces place
ornament on ornament plus flowers plants
growing to the ornaments and the last
project i'll show you is what which is
having the venice biennale which is a
new version of the teasing banda mesa
pavilion the whole thing is not going to
happen anymore so basically what we're
going to do is basically these two guys
with easy structure so we are in the
middle of reshaping that but that was
the original plan to have it was a
fairly small Museum almost like the size
of a big house in Los Angeles some
something like 10,000 square feet but we
stretch it a lot with the landscape I'm
with the structure outside to make it to
make it feel like it was bigger and so
on I told you that we are not really
good at sections and I'm going to hide
it but even the nature what we were
developing with the chairs and with a
lazy start to combine out of those
experiment they happen the small scale
to try to scale up and to take it to the
level of more like a small building so
the thing looks like way bigger than
what it is these are the model then we
produce for the Banali to take the
physicality of the flower into that too
also the thing is therefore pre- hot
weather in Benny's right now it looks
very bad that it smell even worse
which I can likely because we are in the
Austrian pavilion and I don't like most
of the other people in the pavilion but
let's pray that's a different story
another so i'll show you the relation of
the asian then i will present by
critical conclusion with a hammer 357
and so we're going to be perfect
okay to conclude I want to show you a
clip for where I sort of mutate and they
form the title of the lecture I i think
is who I think cowbell more cowbell was
very useful in one moment but I think
right now and he has been became more
clear but really the conclusion so
instead to start from that title of the
lecture I want to finish there and what
sort i meant by that title
you know
I don't want their when you and Brad job
Rachel were being abducted I was sitting
in Gordon's cage now I didn't rig those
charges your men your plan door I really
look like a guard to play him in what I
am I'm a dog chasing cars I don't know
what to do with what if I caught you
know I just do things thank you
regrets that's something I'll do my best
to don't answer them
hi may I ask your question word yeah re
what happened if i say no i can't stop
if you want yeah yeah sure are you an
American citizen no are your giuntini on
yet so to me the presentation of course
it's very much this course of exoticism
right and probably you identify yourself
as an exotic animal pretty much as a
zebra or something really but thank you
so the point I want to say is that in
this idea of Western exoticism you would
project on the exotic a very emo bio and
fixed idea of society right in which you
think that tribes or exotic tribes or
individuals in primitive states are
don't have any historical dimension so
they are always like that eternally
honest so the question I wanted to ask
is that because finally what we saw
where installations museums and
therefore where architectural typology
which are very much they don't question
let's say how society has to be built or
etc so they give a very fix it
imagination of the construction of
society so whatever it was is do you
think that this image of exotic that you
project is somehow self explanatory so
it's autobiographical and therefore you
wouldn't take a charge to discharge that
notion because you are finally not a
citizen or you are a citizen of another
country and therefore you don't play
such a program or you don't think that
in a different construction of types is
a part of the project of exotic as
and therefore you wouldn't do that so
you would do that as a part of is a
coherent and a stylistic coherence or
and I finish here or you don't do this
choice simply because you wouldn't get
any jobs alligator videos on my world so
I have to confess when you asking your
question I feel like poo dl and then
movie with this one with stokey Tokyo
don't mean any only thing he's doing is
imagining can't make it but i'll say no
four points i will be lying if I will
say that those things at any point in
the fur from I understand them I
understand it apart of it I see that
once I let's say a state umbrella i'll
get under the umbrella of autonomy of
the lesion and I think the best i can do
is to try to see how much they can put
to the strings into that and i'll leave
that as a provocation interaction
between the work and whoever will
consume any trouble but we have to be
fair if us to someone must use the end
yell to say that I think that's probably
charge for bed like I think I kind of
got the last way of the usually can be
completely innocent now you said but
choose to these regards I don't think
and also sure it does it do to read that
the guys here they're gonna have so both
of 90s tomatoes are way too many
variables so I might need to figure out
the specific problems of what I can do
with my role
do not try to think much beyond I will
be me I can use a bunch of ones as a lot
of it all relies that recently but the
thing is at some point you did get an
answer at least you get it I'm not sure
with other other weapons
the doctor just saving this for tomorrow
morning ok so today I tell you a lie
tomorrow tell you through the trial yep
and I mean you make me crazy in the way
you talk about your work and it's it
makes me realize how crazy soccer
Socrates must have made everybody around
me would try to come up with a few if
you keep saying that you don't know what
it is that you're doing and you would
always win oh come on I didn't say that
every way up like I have a plan isn't
that exactly that you know I don't tell
us every day of my work doing well
I know what I'm doing I don't know your
mom to a glove if I didn't joke or not
what you doing even if you use it as a
rhetorical trick you you might finish
eating that other people get so crazy
about what you say that they try to
theorize it right and maybe that is a
trick and I am just wondering us at the
beginning of your lecture talked about
your early work and the evolution you
heard what evolution I'm curious how you
make work evolved to me much of this
through our 10 years looks very similar
and you shouldn't be blamed for them I
mean I'm very fascinated but you should
like the worker I don't agree with that
but okay when that would be the answer
to my question how do you how do you
promote yourself to move on because
after all the the model of aesthetic
surgery to bring up down to time or SAS
as a provocation or you know technology
or cinema in any of the above if if they
are pre exchangeable and so easily
exchangeable then how can you take for
instance itamar seriously and and and
really analyze what it has to offer and
then make an architecture that reacts to
that location and it seems to me that
you you throw out metaphors at the at
the same speed at which you invoke them
and then are they really use
to you I mean this is useful to you to
talk about nineteen seventies sex racism
well let's talk about you know what how
is it different from and I know
but give us three examples of how to
work in 2010 is fundamentally different
and using the different provocation than
working to expanding at a time Oh a
couple say well I think to tell you the
absolute truth I'll try my best I always
find that way of questioning like a
short like a cheap trick to tell you the
truth it's like what the people say how
do we know when your forms are ready
three fine let's play I think they work
look first of all I think eight years
the value of working on literature is
not a longer so you can work really very
incremental variations and incremental
steps and it personally think then the
world would produce very reason and we
have nothing to do they say with you to
tell that Europe wrote about it for many
reasons why very simple one and
endeavour was working on a single barrel
of articulation articulating one surface
I think we are way beyond that we are in
moment that the world have to do with
mount for an Englishman surface if I
have to do with the completion with
primitives they have to do with free
choice p on so they're like I will say
like is eternal mechanism i can tell you
how the work evolved from one to the
other so on and so forth in terms of the
provocation of relocation they start to
also move in a way and i will say a porn
whatever the seventh it was useful they
say around appears one time every day
and every I know it's a provocation but
I took it seriously in the sense of
pornography attorney end of the season
and they begin himself it was very
useful 20 very certain other things of
course it may have been widely
whatsoever as a family I will be stupid
not to understand right for the same
time there was in there was a desire to
use that as a liberator
mechanism of provocations 14 but also
the word specific trees they were
borrowing they needs a methodology from
regular film holding into that to excuse
for the ultimate decider which was to
create those moments so in that sense to
me was useful because I would say the
work at the time was only about that the
nation and I think today Allah I like to
think I don't say that approval that the
work is started people different kind of
quality in terms of negotiation with
other things that is not in any longer
about a singular trait I tried to work
both hopefully with multiple pics of the
street I'm did they left the last thing
that I cannot do it I think also the the
nature of the world also had introduced
I need to produce the tray on the angle
that we hold on both with decision he
took 10 to 15 years of the disciplines
going to spend on the funds were and the
glasshouse will notice anything so I
take a look I take responsibility when
people say that but I don't think is
true at all if you look a little hope of
your working 10 years he may have a
certain sensibility that doesn't go away
which old ru happens to most of the
articles and we know but in terms of the
theory specifically technically
methodology is incredibly different
belief if you are you the Stanwich I do
he relax it relies completely on the
level of celebration relation to it but
to me all the provocations the one is
awake also to liberate they all nature
of the work don't be trap is some kind
of external a part of the dozen at least
it doesn't Egypt I don't say the
reporter I
listen I think to me is very functional
to keep the workers a solid as I can
from that so sometimes the provocation
and they should be see wages to liberate
the the other part to work more freely
probably a question I think we have
enough we have a full hour but I
understand when you're driving on and I
take a credit joy that is running but
seriously I think in that friction in
Maryland deflection of the dialogue to
be ich werde territories if you see in
that idea that maybe in a kind of name
way and refuse the world we cage in kind
of a tradition of the discipline in one
way we will tell you with Peter early to
direct resources about that program I'll
take extra decision over to heart and
I'll think about it so to me this
lecture is sort of the conclusion of
eight years and no se muera means that
is the unique easy I'm not saying the
platform for you would keep going I
think certain things you won't need to
change it to something else and will be
the first of the seven the game angry to
the lecture and kind of hungry because
I'm here in the first row
chocolate in like ice cream oh this
thing Fred turn you on thank you the job
is done then this quality of in a few
more like all these categories of the
working with seem to be negated what we
understand as architecture which is
study English from probably very heavy
this video test it but I won't trust how
you do seem to be working on you in to
use negation cool to work that we don't
want it to be like when you work with
autonomy you are getting certain
categories by using the opposite life
life using let this thing that seems
very happy but actual product the world
vacation which we're making up Peter
workers European garden with you will
see these regional autonomy at least
always negating the previous one but
then I think so however you can help me
out here are using you're working with
this isolation
we think this tipping but you need /
architects to see that you do what you
talkin to the opposite of our articles
to or do you negate the outside world
well I would say by no means i claimed
what i do is the truth anything happen
to that it should for me and is useful
for me and being able to work so i think
everybody should study whatever they
feel the ship started to grow into their
own work but in terms of oscillation to
me yeah it's important words of advice
work very very old I see that as an
strength and also see that the witness
don't worry acting so far materials from
that and we don't work with that I
actually that but also said in capacity
of myself to care to those return to
that I really don't have in my
repertoire that part of the problem
[ __ ] a dad when the few things I will
get to feel he became like an
afterthought i'm not i will not allocate
that that's a good thing but me has been
useful to us a vase of the violet for
working hours but that's not really it's
not really new there are many negatives
in history that actually already the
pretty much every architect of murder
i'm not putting myself in a favorable
any analytic model basically absolute
variables and more women two or three
bodies and everything else fall into
that i never trust or gonna not really
try to please every aspect
at least there because I mean the delay
that people who are some environment